all of the rumors that we talk about
here on Sidetrack regarding Stargate are
actually true and a recent podcast has
actually given some credibility to that
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so dial the gate yesterday made a two
hour and a half hour long podcast with
David Reed the host of Dara Sumner from
gateworld and Jenny stiven who is a
consultant for Claire who works within
the industry around MGM and Amazon Etc
and they spoke about the state of
Starkey where we're at
and in this podcast they did mention
Sidetrack quite a bit which was actually
really cool like I'm watching this and
I'm thinking well I'm part of Sidetrack
and
we're getting noticed which is really
really cool and they they start talking
about some rumors that maybe we'll be
perpetuated we've we've spoken about
them and that maybe that's why they're
at the Forefront
um a lot of people
who watch our videos I'm not going to
say all the people that watch our videos
because it's very small number I see
comments every now and then but people
think that we're making it up they think
that
the information that is being fed To Us
by people who work in and around MGM is
false information and I really want to
point out that it's it's not it's not
false information it's not like we're
making it up we're not just pulling
random things out of a hat and saying
well this could happen so let's just say
we got a contact at MGM like we
generally genuinely do have people who
feed us information from MGM and it's
it's one of them things
sometimes when these people give us
information it's true at the time
so there may be a meeting with
um the Amazon marketing department for
example they were talking about Stargate
at one point and they were trying to see
where to where they could go with
Stargate whether they were going to push
forward there and then or whether they
were going to put on the back burn that
is a thing that happened at the time
but it didn't end up being pushed
forward with and that's something
important to remember whenever you watch
any of the videos here on Sidetrack that
the information that we give you is
always going to be up to date at the
time we upload it within a week that
information could be outdated we're
fully aware of that the information
could
become irrelevant like we could say that
horcruxby and Mark Fergus Etc are being
approached by Amazon and MGM to to join
Stargate and create a show Bible and see
what they can do with the show that
information is true and you'll see that
later on there's a clip about that
but it may not be true forever and
that's always something to keep in mind
but let's watch a few clips and
hopefully you'll get a better
understanding of how the industry works
and more importantly you'll realize that
we don't just do this because we want
views we want to give you the most up to
information and I think this really does
give that some more credibility but
enough of that let's just watch some
clips
to know from your guys's point
some of the rumors I think we just need
to to say Hey look
none of us know if any of these rumors
are going to come through because like
I've said
all of us who are talking about Stargate
online on YouTube writing about it on
gateworld David talking about it with
dial the gate and talking with Talent
who actually does talk because they're
still in production they talk to
producers and show Runners and people in
Vancouver who are all still connected or
Toronto or L.A all of these rumors may
be true at that moment
but then wait two weeks it's like
whatever they say about the weather in
Chicago right it's like wait a moment
the weather changes wait two weeks and
the Rumor will be dead and then there's
a new room yeah essentially everything
I've just said there are rumors that go
around the MGM offices around Amazon and
because Jay is in touch with quite a lot
of these people I know of
at least five that he's in touch with
those people who share information the
information they've given at the time is
probably correct it's what they've heard
it's what's being chatted about within
the office and they've seen a meeting go
on and then they've shared that
information and
our channel is slightly different to
other channels who talk about Stargate
any information that we get we share
with you because we want to share
everything about Stargate now a lot of
these uh rumors and things they don't
they turn out that maybe they're
slightly slightly inaccurate or maybe
they were true at the time but they're
no longer true
a good example of this is when Brad
Wright was in conversation with Amazon
and MGM about his new script now we've
been talking about the fact that Brad
Wright script hasn't been
hasn't been on the cards for a really
long time it was later confirmed by Brad
on Twitter that he's not being pushed
he's not pushing forward with
with his script as a result of these
meetings they're going to be pushing on
with someone else now something that's
really interesting in this video here is
they actually talk about one of the
rumors that we spoke about here on this
channel and that is regarding
two very important people from the
expanse so let's quickly have a look at
that so Janet before I interrupted you
with that question we were talking about
um MGM Amazon soliciting pitches and
Mark Fergus and as far as you know right
right
in the rumors that some of the more
successful genre shows that have been on
Amazon like the boys and the expanse
yeah
those writers have pitched or have been
invited to pitch something Stargate
related
people who had done it prior to the buy
and then Amazon because of its sci-fi
Silo had sent out the call for lots of
sci-fi fantasy and still are it's still
a silo they're really working as well as
procedural and some others that they've
decided to focus on so
one of the things that was done was that
they would say with certain production
companies that they had either already
worked with or were really excited about
like Mark Fergus and Hawk his partner
and said hey we loved what you've done
what would you like to do we'd love to
get and they said my understanding is
they said starting now I've I had heard
this prior to when uh Sidetrack had
talked about it
I didn't I didn't know for sure if it
was real because again you hear a lot of
comments sometimes or rumors that are
um what's the word I want uh trying to
make something happen so that kind of
confirmed the theory or the rumor that
Mark Fergus and horcoxby were approached
by Amazon it's something that we've
mentioned here on the channel before we
made a whole video about it and we spoke
about it on all of our live shows that
we talk about it's something we talk
about on a regular basis because it's
something we're excited about it's a
it's a potential of well the expanse is
great the expanse is fantastic we
absolutely love it and if those guys are
involved Stargate could be amazing when
it returns because honestly we believe
that it's going to return because of all
the rumors that we hear we have people
in around MGM talking about everything
that happens there is conversations are
happening all the time and we honestly
believe it will return and if those guys
are involved
it's gonna be amazing and the reason we
we share this information with you is
because we want you to get excited about
Stargate as well we want you to to know
exactly what's going on
and it may not be true forever Mark
Ferguson horcoxby May pull out they may
decide that they no longer want to you
know push forward with Stargate and then
someone else could come in and when that
information comes in if and when we'll
keep you updated because that's the kind
of Channel we are we're just going to
give you the most up-to-date information
when we can and eventually when there is
a press release and
Stargate is pushed the Forefront by
Amazon they said we're definitely going
to go ahead with it these are the guys
that are involved we'll start talking
about with a little bit more facts but
until then all we can really rely on is
the fact that we've got contacts in
around MGM who are just feeding this
information
we are essentially the vehicle of
sharing what is going on in the back end
we don't know for a hundred percent
what's gonna happen but we know the
conversations are happening and that's
what we're trying to to do we're just
trying to share with you the most
up-to-date information that we can now
I'm going to leave a link to this entire
podcast in the description of this video
and I really recommend you go and watch
it because I have always loved dial the
gay I've always loved gateworld I've
loved the podcast you know all of those
channels before I started on Sidetrack I
was of just a regular viewer I've always
been a YouTuber but on the Sci-Fi side
on the Stargate side of things I've
always just been a viewer like trying to
keep up to date with the most up-to-date
information and I am very much like you
guys I found Sidetrack because I was
interested in Stargate before Sidetrack
I was watching Dart of the gate I was
watching gate world I was watching
podcast and I thought I was getting the
most up-to-date information and that is
until I discovered the Sidetrack Channel
and then eventually I joined and here I
am
sharing information with you
and and this is this is such a crazy
like situation for me to be in because
I'm just a guy from the UK who makes
videos and loves a show called Stargate
and now I'm part of a channel that is
giving information about a new potential
series before anyone else is even
talking about it it's really exciting
for me but like I said I'm going to
leave the information or a link to that
video in the description down below and
I really urge you to go and watch it
it's two and a half hours long it's a
pretty long watch but it's really really
interesting all that's left to do is for
me to say goodbye thank you so much for
watching if you did enjoy the video give
me a like And subscribe to the YouTube
channel so you don't miss a single video
we make content about Stargate all the
time and any information that we get
from MGM or Amazon we're going to share
with you as and when it comes in and if
you're a regular viewer consider
becoming a fully flashlight tracker by
pressing the join button down below
thank you so much for watching there
will be a live show tonight I will see
you all there
take care
[Music]